I was proposed to on a party bus
on the way on the way to a Chris Angel
show in Vegas my parents were there
Todd's parents were there my brothers
and their wives were there what's like
tell me like the moment like are you
sitting there on the party bus like and
what happened I'm okay I'm like I you
know I'm I'm wearing the the mom jeans
in the family and uh so you know I'm
like if I don't get my engagement ring
in Vegas like Todd's gonna be have two
black eyes Okay Todd's gonna get his his
ass whooped by two black guys buy two
black guys yes and um they were in the
party bus which was just in case he
didn't do it uh I like hired muscle to
force him to do it so I knew like I had
a feeling that because all our family
was coming that this was going to be the
moment he was doing it and I wanted I
mean I obviously would like as cheesy as
possible so I did get
uh no shade Chris Angel you are a little
cheesy but um my manager is has a
Connect and so I got my whole party into
this Chris Angel show
and I was like I was I thought maybe
like Chris Angel would come from the
ceiling reveal like his nipple ring was
really an emerald
and proposed to me but
um I guess Chris Angel was like no
proposals at my show he has like a
policy about yeah he was like he didn't
want it in the vicinity like on the he
didn't want to end the casino did his
parents get divorced like what's the
issue
I don't know what the trauma is but I
did we did go backstage and hang out
with him and and he congratulations he
knew it happened he was happy I guess it
didn't happen in front of him it would
have been so embarrassing honestly if
Chris Angel was there
stop wasting your money on things you
don't use cancel your unwanted
subscriptions and manage your money the
easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday that's rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday rocketmoney.com trash
Tuesday go to drinksimplyspiked.com
trash Tuesday to find out how to get
your hands on simply spiked lemonade and
new simply spiked Peach that's
drinksimplyspiked.com trash Tuesday hi
slugs I am on the road and I am so
excited to see you guys at my shows this
month I will be in Oxnard August 27th
and then I'll be in Madison Wisconsin
September 14th through 16th and then
September 28th DC and finally September
30th The Wilbur in Boston and then I
will be in Chicago San Diego Detroit and
so much more get tickets at
astronice.com yo what up it's me Annie I
am on the road I'm doing my welcome to
anniewood tour you can see me next in on
the 20 27th I will be in Calgary with
Andrew Schultz at The Great Outdoors
Comedy Festival that's going to be so
fun I'll be in San Francisco at Cobb
September 15th and 16th I'll be in
Austin Texas October 6th and 7th La
Jolla Comedy Store October 13th and 14th
San Jose Houston Texas and a lot more
shows go to annieleterman.com shows
[Music]
foreign
I can't believe you weren't embarrassed
in front of your family like to me the
thought of being proposed to in front of
any other person is so humiliating
listen there were humiliating elements
to it but there was a rage that filled
me when I tell you what happened there
was a rage that filmed me that took over
any emotions to the point where I did
not even feel engaged till 24 hours
later because the rage was so real so
Todd so the stones are Family Stone so
it's a emerald from my great great aunt
it's from the 1800s it's like this like
amazing thing my mom found and then the
diamonds around it are from Todd's Mom's
tennis bracelet so we had all of these
these gems and and I was I had a friend
uh
I guess I he wasn't that good of a
friend I thought he was a better friend
uh this guy who hangs out of The Comedy
Store who's a comic and okay
guys at The Comedy Store he's so dead to
me we just we dragged him on anniewood
like he's going down
his nickname is heavy it's like all of
the signs were to not trust this person
I trusted him he would always bring
jewelry around I don't know I was like
wait I know heavy from Toronto done wait
why have he's the biggest piece of [__]
on Earth [__] heavy you're trash I
hate you I will say this I never would
have gone to him for jewelry
he like up charged us by the way there
was like a there was like an initial
charge then it all of a sudden got more
expensive he doesn't do any of it I
found out now once he screwed up the
ring well he's not a real Jeweler he
just sourced this thing he just sources
things and doesn't check them or make
sure that they were done correctly or
anyway so Todd on the party bus I'm
surprised because I think it's gonna
happen at the Criss Angel show so on the
party bus we got on it's perfect it's so
cheesy it's like exactly how I wanted
Todd's all nervous he's like well will
you be my wife forever like said
something so stupid and um and I'm like
I'm like yes and then he hands with
everyone but you're supposed to put it
on thank God he wasn't the one because
he would have gotten the direction of
the anger because I would have been
looking at him so I go to put it on and
it doesn't fit over my the first knuckle
of my ring finger this [__] [__]
did not resize the ring when I gave it
to him it was a size four was a pinky
ring he never resized that you had paid
to get it we paid to resize it he
measured my finger Todd double checked
made sure that he was like had the sizes
and everything he just didn't do his job
you know a little too late now but we
could have really used Nicholas potash
for this Nick you Scott I claim you for
this no but it was like so it was a
pinky ring which is like what if I had
popped out and been like it fits me
hi Todd you were driving the car
um
so mad so like the engagement uh video
is like me getting engaged being excited
going to put it on and then I like
looked at Cameron like [__] heavy
like it's just it's so crazy he also had
been showing everyone the ring before I
got it it was just like so
unprofessional the whole thing was so
annoying it was like thousands of
dollars more than he said it was gonna
be for no reason nothing changed it was
like and then when I text him about it
he was like oh sorry your first
engagement didn't go perfectly like I
was like being some sort of like prima
donna about a deal we had made where he
had promised uh to do a craft that he
said he did he does and then it was I
don't do any of it people's weight
fluctuates he told me that it was
probably weight gain that made it a
pinky ring I mean I was so mad I'm not
the authority on jewelry but I did date
a jeweler for like an extended period he
did come on your back
um but that is [__] up isn't that then
he goes this happens to me once a year
I'm like why would this happen to you
once a year what and then he was trying
to blame his like workers I'm like you
are the person I trusted you are the
person I paid you are the person and by
the way I had to pay some of it because
he up charged it like Todd had it
covered and then I had he just ruined
everything but it was funny he also
didn't resize Todd's when he was
supposed to resize Todd's right why does
Todd have a ring because his dad's ring
doesn't fit him anymore so he gave him
his room so Todd's been for the future
has Todd such no he just wears it yeah
God wears a wedding ring no rings on men
are so hot like Signet Rings or even
when they have big bold like tourmaline
rings there's not so sexy I love that
you're engaged to Todd but he's married
to you like right that's a really good
that's a good I mean it's just a miracle
I didn't propose to him
that's my one gender like my My Line in
the Sand okay that might be my Line in
the Sand too I have friends I have
friends that my friend Brendan was or
Brandon was proposed to by his wife and
I am like not okay with it
well now that you guys are so against it
I'm like hmm is there one for your next
one no for when we re-up the engagement
but I have to say I know how you feel
because when Dave proposed to me the
ring it was too big and it didn't fit
and I was like
I I like put a Band-Aid around it and
wore it anyway but I
I don't know it does feel like you want
it to be magical and perfect so I think
it's probably really common at least I
would have been okay with it being too
big though like it's just I couldn't see
what it looked like on the finger like
it didn't fit on like the finger it was
supposed to go on my dreams of having
the perfect engagement ring are gone
because of us no because I am not dating
a jeweler anymore yeah like it would
have been the best he would have made it
the [__] he's a very unique Jeweler too
would have been really like yeah well
I'll have him redo my ring because I
want nothing I want no heavy on my
absolutely go to Nick for that because
he will make it the best after we got
engaged like so I had to get the ring
size fixed and so Dave worked with this
Jeweler that like he knew from college
or whatever and so we were both texting
her she didn't she literally ghosted US
10 days went by I'm like wow this is
actually never happened in my life I've
never just been dropped and then after
10 days so many times since then after
10 days she's like just got home from
burning man sorry you're like oh thank
God because I was so and I was panicked
I was like oh my ring like the Jeweler
abandoned yeah I know and you do want it
back like a media yeah you want it right
well Todd's parents are amazing so my
older brother and Todd's dad like the
minute this happened it was you know
seven o'clock at night they were like on
the phone calling Jewelers like getting
it fixed it was so cute so Todd's
parents we went to the mall to like a
quick fix or whatever and how perfect is
that I know it's so sweet but then it
ended up being too big because
the guy who like fixed it took so long
to do it that Todd's parents were just
sitting at this mall in Vegas for hours
while the rest of the family was like
partying and having fun and
uh waiting for the ring and it took so
long and then the guy just made it two
sizes bigger than he had measured I mean
it's like Jewelers or not
why is it so hard no he was late too and
he did look like he had been raving the
night before
I was like dude he only makes nipple
rings I was like now when it happened
like literally when Todd was on his knee
and you're on the party bus like were
you did you cry did you were you
overcome with emotions like I was
surprised I didn't think I didn't think
he was going to be able to surprise me
because I had choreographed so much of
it but I was really surprised by it I'm
really glad that Chris Angel hates love
um because it did it was like it was
really cute and he did it really fast
like right when we got on the party bus
like Josh started putting music on Josh
Potter was with us what song was playing
I don't remember I thought it was like
celebrate I thought like Josh put on
like a bar mitzvah like gosh was so
excited to be the DJ it was so cute he
was like more excited than everyone when
I got proposed to we're like who's gonna
be the DJ and Tacos why don't you be the
DJ Josh and Josh was like yes and I was
like laughing at that when Todd proposed
because I was like oh Josh is so happy
was everyone like looking at you
everyone had their cameras off they were
all so excited oh my God and then when I
was pissed everyone was trying to be
like it's fine it's fine but it's like
on my pinky it's not okay it was not
okay I'm like you don't understand I
literally paid this man I looked him in
the eye I trusted him he showed my
manager goes oh your Ring's so pretty I
haven't got my ring yet why are you he
was oh heavy showed us why are you
showing people my ring before I get it
yeah and by the way he's taking credit
for it this is the same design of the
Ring we gave him it's just different no
person you designed nothing also again
like
Nick looks at my finger and he's like
you're a four and a half your main
finger's a foreign my ring finger is I'm
tiny well I had a ring for you the other
day
we both could have married Todd we had
our chance
yeah I um you have tiny fingers too long
but they're slender yeah slender
Slenderman's hands Slenderman
um I remember when when Dave proposed to
me he played the song Miley Cyrus Adore
You that's really which was cute like we
were driving to couples therapy it is so
funny he did it on the way to couples I
know and didn't cancel so we had to pay
the fee but
like I he I just remember I was like
sitting in the car and we were driving
and then that song came on and I was
like what and then I could see you as
like going off course and but like can I
tell you the minute that song played I
got nervous like did you feel that like
awkward shy uncomfortable I felt weird
after we were engaged like I felt like
ew like
ew it's like embarrassing to tell people
you're engaged it yes it's like I watch
Netflix shows with someone now forever
like it's like you don't know it's like
telling I don't know there's something
like that's just like mine show offiness
about it that you don't feel I don't
know it's like I I was so happy to be
engaged I I begged for it but like
there's something about that actual
moment that is so uncomfortable I the
moment was good the heavy thing
Beyonce is so disgusting
fiance is so snobby and gross and you
and I every I have so many jokes about
Todd it's like boyfriend is cute I know
Beyonce is like this has been my issue
for five years what do you think of
husband husband's better yeah when
someone says my wife it it it lands
husband is way better my husband but
isn't boyfriend cuter boyfriend's Cupid
on I'll never have a boyfriend again I
want to go back to Dave being my boy bye
yay hi how's it going hi I'm kalila next
to you yes
I like your jeans is Robert here
oh cool he can come in whenever he's
doing touch-ups he's a pretty boy
yeah no but there is it is like it's
embarrassing it's like too much
information I want to know what that
feeling is and should I feel like a lot
of girls probably feel this way but no
one talks about it because it's supposed
to be the happiest moment but I'm I
believe you guys okay I can I can almost
feel what you're feeling and I've never
been there it's a feeling that I don't
feel like I've had
since childhood you know what it is it's
puberty it's a transition you're in a
transitional period yeah that you're
like you're going through in front of
you yeah people are watching you like
change into something else
oh Robert
[Applause]
what did you order
um we ordered um a chest plate for
Esther
a chest plate wait welcome to the show
Robert Schwartzman
are you how do you feel right now are
you overwhelmed I feel really good no I
no you do feel comfortable I feel really
hot I want to stay here yeah is there a
blanket or anything there is a blanket
is there a seat wormer I could have or
something no I feel great I just feel
like I don't want to say anything that
I'm not supposed to say really well no
about like what just like Hollywood and
stuff oh yeah you're fine no strikes
we're just talking about
um and getting the ick when getting
proposed to oh yeah oh the feeling you
got apparently when Annie felt that
that's not an ick but it said well being
engaged is like embarrassed I don't know
there's something embarrassing did you
when you will you tell us from the other
tell us from the other perspective oh
that's where I would tell you anything
oh I love this anything I
um
yeah I'll tell you what you want to know
my engagement story yeah yeah okay are
you sure yes okay
um so I um I married my uh someone that
I went to elementary school with
yeah
so I was we met in first grade
yeah no I we went we grew up in Los
Angeles together it was a school called
um ues which stands for University
Elementary School oh my God
no but it's now well now it's called the
lab school which I don't know maybe
that's worse I know exactly yeah well
because everyone's a test tube baby it
was it's called seeds oh God even worse
embryonic yeah sorry sorry it sounds
like a biotech I know it's true it's
true well it's weird because it was on
the UCLA so on the UCLA campus along the
edge of it on Sunset Boulevard is a
elementary school it's a really good
school it's great
and is it so good that like you can just
stop there after Elementary School yeah
just get married you find your wife
your whole career I shouldn't have said
the name of the school but no it was it
was it was it's a great anyway I didn't
just say the name of the school you said
all of them
I know you can't exactly now you guys
can all research this but so I'm we met
Zoe my wife Zoe which I love her she's
such a talented photographer and she's
so beautiful like she's awesome yeah
she's amazing she's awesome
so we yeah so first grade I'm one year
above her sore we had mixed grades so
yeah I know two I think maybe I was
second she was in first grade but we so
we met at that school you know you have
a lot of memories I don't know if you
guys feel this way but when you're you
know you have like visual memories of
people you went to school with yeah you
know you just like you kind of know if
you close your eyes right now you could
see somebody yeah that gets out of my
car yeah
that little bastard over there so yeah I
buy cars are weird yeah yes well so we
weird about hips you know I'm weird
about hips
I'm sorry no tell me I want to know I
don't even know what's going on what is
the hip thing and he gets it in my crown
[__] my tiara oh yeah we are in Princess
Diaries oh cool for you yeah that's
amazing they're our first friends yeah
princess diary you're our second
princess
oh cool my crown Esther's the before
Prince you're the after I really
appreciate that when you kiss Esther you
turn into you
foreign
s draining your wallet Esther yes as a
matter of fact like I am subscribed to
every streaming service I don't use them
like I have lost track it's just I sign
up for everything so quickly so easy on
a whim well here's a fun fact for you
the average person has around 12 paid
subscriptions and they might not even
remember subscribing to half of those
yeah it's it's like I have 80d so I'm
gonna I'll do the the seven day trial
and then I'm like oh I'll cancel this
later and then you know and they
intentionally make it very difficult to
find the cancel button
um but enter rocket money rocket money
is a personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place most
people think they're spending eighty
dollars on their subscriptions when in
reality the number is closer to two
hundred dollars when you're signed up
for so many things like streaming
services you use to watch one show or
free trials for liver you don't use it's
easy to lose track of what you're paying
for oh and Rocket money by the way can
even negotiate to lower your bills for
you by up to twenty percent it's not
that they just cancel your unwanted
subscriptions they can lower your bills
as well all you have to do is take a
picture of your bill and Rocket money
takes care of the rest stop wasting
money on things you don't use cancel
your unwanted subscriptions and manage
your money the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday that's
rocketmoney.com Tuesday rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday you guys it's been a
really hot
and what I have in my hand is not just
any Hard Lemonade simply Spike lemonade
has been bringing the juiciness since
launching last summer in four bold
flavors that are perfect for any
occasion pick up a variety package try
each flavor including signature lemonade
strawberry lemonade blueberry lemonade
and watermelon lemonade by popular
demand four fan favorite Peach flavors
are now also part of the simply spiked
family
signature Peach strawberry peach kiwi
Peach and mango peach which one are you
I'm kiwi Peach I'm signature you guys
this is actually really really tasty
stuff it smells so so refreshing on a
hot day
um if you're out if you're going to a
summer party this is the drink I think
to bring I have a friend who had a
barbecue out in Marina del Rey and I
brought a case of the simply spiked
Peach and people were so into it they're
like oh my God this is cute fruity cute
cool girl Vibes go to drink
simplyspike.com trash Tuesday to find
out how to get your hands on simply
spiked lemonade and new simply spiked
Peach that's
drinksimplyspiked.com trash Tuesday
flavored beer naturally flavored with
other natural flavors simply spiked Co
Milwaukee Wisconsin celebrate
responsibly simply spiked and simply
spiked lemonade our trademarks of the
Simply Orange Juice company
[Music]
I know
to get through the story basically you
know we met at the school
you know I grew up in Los Angeles right
so we grew up in La too so we're both
from La so you've been through that
together yeah
and we um so we have these memories of
like ues that school ended at sixth
grade then you go to like junior high so
we all went to different schools so we
kind of like everyone goes their
separate ways so that's when I like
didn't see Zoe again
until we were like in our you know late
20s we started dating were you that girl
with the barrettes that I used to look
at wait no she know I totally remember
Zoe so her name is Zoe gross and you
recognized everybody wants right on
Instagram and wait did you have a crush
on her in elementary school well it's
interesting like I don't know if if it
how what level of crush like one felt
compared to how we Crush now but the no
she she uh no but I just always
remembered Zoe and she had the same
group of friends so I kind of remembered
like you ever you know Social Circles
formed at that age so you kind of
remember who was hanging with who and on
the on the playground I played like
kickball and Zoe was playing handball
we have these memories Esther so relax
that's okay no but we so I so I wanted
to I wanted to propose a Zoe and I and I
well first this would happen how long
were you together so we were
we were living well we we were together
for like two years and then she moved in
what happened was we broke up
temporarily yes I had one of those freak
out phases where
I had I had directed my first feature
film what was it called it was called
Dreamland Dreamland check it out and I
felt like oh wow I'm like discovering a
new part of myself like creatively and
when you're on did you feel a little
like I'm gonna get some like director
plus oh my God be honest no no I know
what no okay all right just I just asked
what well that's what I would think I'd
be like oh [__] you would want tractor
plus I'm Annie bonus Letterman when I
have success things get wet things are
crazy
possible possibilities have women around
you are getting one my special comes out
Todd better watch out
there it is right there it's like five
dreamlands
um
isn't that great
so okay so you're having this crazy in
this movie I kind of like was really
overwhelmed I got swept into that
feeling of like being on set you're with
your crew it's a family feeling and
you're just like I think I felt
you know my my mom I grew up with a
mother who's an actress right and she's
like a real intense artist she's very
like intense in a good way but she's
just like Robert you're making I really
focus you gotta like just everything
you're gonna like really throw yourself
into this it's your first feature so I
felt all this like these voices in my
head making me feel a lot of pressure
and then I started like maybe kind of
feeling overwhelmed having balancing a
relationship and then trying to make a
movie all in La too you're not like away
on location checking out so I was like
trying to find a way to find Harmony
between work life and then personal life
which was hard can I interject here that
that is a common thing I feel like
especially that men experience that
maybe we don't necessarily which is like
if you are going to the if you're going
by tradition of like taking on a wife
you do probably want to feel like more
set in your career and not in this like
beginning stage so I can kind of see
getting to the end of the story no we
look this is a week we want this story
what if I don't even get to the
performance the last episode was just me
telling one story we don't want you to
finish okay good we but how old are we
ones yeah well well I I spent a lot of
my life doing music playing in I started
a band called Rooney and I would tour as
Rooney
I only know like Britney Spears music so
I wasn't aware but I think that's a good
thing if I was I love this oh yeah no
wrong spelling
honestly the other Dreamland
um well I love the zero
that's my DJ spelling hey all right hey
are you an alien yeah there you go oh my
gosh okay so you had done music you were
born with the hair to do this too yeah
you had to you couldn't uh that's some
on-camera hair
um so I uh whoa look at that cute
um yeah so I was touring I spent a lot
of time touring I push pause I want to
like take a break from taurine and
making records and like direct a movie
so I was I don't know I was like 30
like three or something I don't know
yeah something like that but I like what
whatever to long story short my personal
life was kind of like feeling the pre
like the I don't know be being close to
somebody who was trying to figure out
how to make a movie and all that
pressure
so you know Zoe was amazingly supportive
during that time but I just unfairly I
just had like a sort of panic at the end
of it
and we had like a breakup and she moved
out it was really sad and we had a dog
together that she I remember her driving
away with it so he's listening right now
Zoey
she in the future she's listening but
yeah it was like it was yeah it was like
really sudden and really hard mostly I
will say for her because you see we're
on set because
you were like doing the thing no because
she moved out of a house that he shared
she had moved in and then moved out and
that was more more on her attitude and
how long had it all that's you have to
moving sucks right yeah and then there's
a breakup it's an emotional piece move
out yeah but then but then I then I had
this like Panic of like why did I what
did I do I made a big mistake I need to
go back and fix this right
so I started like and I saw I was with
some family members who love Zoe so much
and we were all together and I like they
were like where's Zoe right now and I
was like well we broke up and they
couldn't believe what I had just said
they were so upset that this had
happened and that I had let whatever
actions I had chosen to take led to this
outcome
and they were like this is a big mistake
and you need to like fix this and I was
I knew in my mind I was like yes this is
a rom-com like the whole family's like
all right so we're gonna plan this now
they're like driving what's so nice
because everyone really did like really
really loved her so much so it was and
what family members because I know like
this could be like Nicholas Cage
you really want to know yeah well no
I'll say literally Francis Coppola
told me you need to go back and he we're
on our way to New York together and he
said I know a guy who sells diamonds in
the Diamond District I know a guy that
has a winery who's like you know
something that people sell privately
like you buy a diamond you have to you
have to you have to set it and
everything but you can buy them
separately yeah we just talked about the
guy that Annie used and she hates him
covered that like what you're wearing uh
well anyway so he said you need to call
this man it was very old school like
call this guy go pick out a diamond and
then go you need to go back and propose
to her and and like not like for not
forces it is like this is a movie Family
like that's like a movie Family let's go
from breakup to engagement and then when
I was in New York
because you know when you go through I
mean I was not feeling
settled inside like I had you know I
just it didn't feel I had made this
really quick decision it was totally not
thought through
the the breakup so I was carrying with
me this uncertain feeling of like
unresolved tension of did I make a big
mistake so like so cinnamon I know this
is what oh at that point yeah like two
weeks now when you were in New York was
there a girl like a short girl
pretending to be shot by paparazzi
well so so I um and then when I was on
that trip this is more it gets more
movie-like but I was like with the
family with family and and my like my
grandfather's brother who's like in his
late like he passed away but he was in
his like 90s still married to the same
his same marriage was it Paul Newman no
but but they were like this they're a
sweet older couple who like live and
breathe New York you would have them on
the show if you like the very much like
New York all the way forever
and and they were like what are you
doing go you gotta marry this girl she
sounds like amazing and just don't like
get in your head just do it like ever
you know she was just they were telling
me you know you're overthinking all this
stuff and like I told him why we broke
up and it was just that this makes sense
because that's the Italian yeah and you
have the Jewish side yeah exactly like
wrestling exactly but it was just nice
to meet all these people that had like
been married for so long and you could
see it and you're like yeah what am I
you're right God I'm so stupid so I like
I like at some point I like I showed up
at Zoe's place with like flowers
or I'm not on Easter I like broader than
Easter basket with like chocolates in it
or something and then I start every day
I sent her breakfast on like GrubHub or
something and I think I sent her flowers
like every day because she definitely
would not take me back
good for her she wouldn't she did not
take me back and I had to really she
will she she wanted me to fight for her
and she she was at every right that was
the right decision and I tried I just
did everything I could to kind of like
make sure she knew I was like that's a
great move though what kind of thing was
a different breakfast every day or I
think it was yeah it was different every
day yeah
no no I know
she would have been like who's like I
would have lost enter the same breakfast
burritos every day yeah from different
places lucky boys
but I sent her flowers I sent her
desserts I sent her whatever I could and
then I
I think I did look at diamonds it's so
stupid because I didn't we weren't even
back but I looked at diamonds and like I
did some research and then but this is
where the story gets exciting so I'm so
yeah well no she wanted me to like take
her like today almost like date her
again so I like started I took her out
to dinner and like picked her up and
like tried to be romantic and said let's
get dressed up and I tried to make it
like you know just try to like kind of
win her back
and then eventually we started seeing
each other again
and then
to jump ahead I was like okay I should
it's funny because I was like I'm gonna
go I Frances pumped me up to just like
get a ring and just go back and do it
like a movie right yeah just get on your
knees and just be like I'm sorry babe
here's my ring I know that purposely
have to be on both knees
I had a family member say that's a
terrible idea
she's like don't do that who is she
she Sophia Coppola yeah really this is
fun you keep guessing right though but
you have yeah no no Sophia said don't do
that that's a terrible idea I think
you're really gonna freak her out and
it's way too sure like Herky jerky to
just be like let's break up move out and
then where's my ring it won't feel it
won't carry what it should be which is
this authentic like this is the right
time I don't know but I feel like Eyes
Wide Shut really like delved into
marriage and yeah that is a good female
director
you know Virgin Suicides was okay well
no so I so I took that voice was in the
back of my head and all these voices are
in my head again you can see voices are
in my head there's a theme you're
Herman's Head my mom's voice yeah it's
like trying to get understand where is
your voice and all this but so I'm like
just I need to just take my time and
like start to get back into like a
rhythm together so we started so we got
back together but there was always that
feeling of like
having to figure out this new patent
this a new Dynamic together after going
through a breakup that was a little bit
like well did sudden and weird that it
yeah did you feel like she then kind of
started to be like I'm the director now
like you want me back like oh Joey yeah
um yeah no no photography so she
probably is directing people she she got
her own place and she was totally set
and she kind of you know she set up her
life you know like I it was weird to go
to her place and see her new life it was
bizarre and she she was you know like
she had put her she'd bought she'd found
the pieces she needed to feel secure
again
and then here I am coming back the
person who made life not secure yeah
trying to then ask her to let's move
back in together that was like a huge
No-No yeah she was like no
she was she said no I thought it was
like on Valentine's Day or something I
thought I could romantically like we
could move in together like I got you a
card so I so I did buy I did buy a ring
right I bought a ring
and I had thought of how I was gonna
propose so what I was going to do was
I was going to somehow get her back to
elementary school so I could propose on
campus that's cute right hard to get on
elementary schools really hard right
I try so I email court orders honestly I
was able to get the right person's
contact I emailed them hi we both went
here I want to propose to her here
so I knew I so I knew there was how do I
get her back there without knowing
anything's upright so I said to the
school can you email Zoe saying we've
recently have done remodeling and we
found old uh papers and how artwork and
stuff that belonged to you when you were
in school here would you please come
pick it up or we will have to like
dispose of it like by this date wait I
have a question was she disappointed
when there wasn't because that would be
such a goal it's gonna get really wild
so so I so they were willing to send out
this very like formal email very
official and she got the email and I
knew they had sent it and then I kind of
I I was like oh I she didn't mention
anything to me and I thought she would
certainly say something but she doesn't
like look at her phone all the time at
all the emails right
so she kind of missed the email oh no
and I was like hey I got this email from
ues too hey did you get and then she
checks out oh my God I got one too and I
was like oh we should go get these paper
we should go pick this stuff up so she's
like okay good idea so we like set the
date to go get it
and then what I did was I went to an art
store and I made like fake artwork
as if it was like from back in the day
like crane like paper you know like
paper and crayons and weird was it hard
to make it like I made yeah yeah I
literally made a packet of like fake kid
artwork but in it we're like baked sort
of like poems about Merit like love and
I think I wrote like something a poem in
it I wrote in like crayons but did you
write it with like your yeah like that
yeah exactly and then I left all this
stuff there like a packet of it at the
school
and then it was all set and then Zoe's
like oh no I I she's a photographer
fashion photographer a shoot came up and
I can't go on that day now and I have to
go to New York
and I had this feeling of I gotta do it
like I had that voice of gotta go
propose you know like just do this I had
the ring and everything ready so what we
were what happened was we weren't able
to go to the school and uh and do the
whole thing right and it was all set so
I was and then we had we went to New
York together and I was like I for some
reason I I think I I don't know why I
felt like I have to propose now
like right away like as if like
something you're gonna miss a flight or
something right
so I was like [__]
the ues thing's not going to work out
but it was like so that was so right so
I'm gonna have to do it in New York
right
sorry that's your face I can't believe
the ues thing isn't happening
the plot thickens so we go to New York
and I'm thinking to myself okay I've got
to do this in New York of this I gotta
where do I do it that's like sentimental
or something so I'm like how about
Liberty Island like the statue yeah
I know so I'm like you know we are are
like our relatives came through Ellis
Island
I know that's why it's so happy like oh
my God I know that's again we're gonna
get back to it so we go to New York
together I have the ring the in the in
the safe in the hotel room Zoe has no
idea
and I keep thinking to myself maybe like
what I had been told like don't this
could freak her out if it's too sudden
and then I started Googling like best
ways to propose or like things to know
when you this really silly but one of
the things was like don't make sure you
sort of talk to your partner
in advance or get some fee feedback on
if she's ready or you know like is it
the right time right
so I started doing that the night before
I was gonna propose I was like so how
are you feeling and
she started picking up on this intense
energy for me and she was like look if
you're about to like do any like if if
why are you asking me these questions
and like it kind of gave me the vibe
like don't do anything extreme right now
sort of the vibe because it was very
fresh right all this coming back
so I was like oh [__] okay that was that
was just think about all this island
yeah exactly crying all this was in the
back of my mind right we go to Liberty
Island I like I'm like let's go to this
would be so fun this is like where our
relatives came so we walk in circles
around Liberty Island I'm holding the
ring in my jacket pocket there's like
school kids running around because
there's like tours going on and I'm like
where am I gonna drop on my knees and do
this I'm looking around my hand is like
shaking
and then I have that doubt that voice
going don't she said like don't do this
right now what am I doing this is so
stupid so I did I ended up and she kept
saying why are you acting so weird like
you're acting so weird because I kept
going wow I look amazing it's always so
awesome I kept looking I kept like
walking around like oh this is so
beautiful she's like trolling you on
your own like wow this is amazing like
look at this place you know she's like
she's like why I know exactly hear her
she's like what are you talking about so
I just she's like you're acting so weird
what's going on I'm like oh it's just so
it's so sentimental being here so anyway
long story short I didn't do it I was
like I can't do this right now yeah what
a really so I put the ring back in the
box and I left it there and I think
maybe two and a half years passed by two
years passed by two years movie it's
like you're you're because two years
because you know what happened we ended
up we what we ended up doing was we
everything was we were in a good spot we
ended up buying a house together in Echo
Park and that was like the beginning of
this joint of like a part partnership
right was the first Act of a real like
joint like this isn't she's living in my
place I'm living in her place but let's
get a place together so that was the
beginning of setting up these like Roots
together
and that's kind of created some great
momentum I think it was around maybe a
year and a half two years the ring was
in a bag in like a back room closet
hidden away and it was so weird because
in the back of my mind I was like man I
have this ring
what I'm like I got what is this gonna
happen so I reset up the ues thing again
I had ues new email saying hey we've
postponed construction or whatever the
stuff is still here
I was texting with like the whoever was
the contact there hey we're on our way
got her in the car got to you yes it was
after hours it was like Sunset it was
like getting dark outside we were the
only ones there we got knocked on talk
on the door oh hey come in oh yeah let
me go get your papers just take it take
them you guys are free to walk around
I'll be right back you know the woman
working there said that [__] was all
like set so she disappears and I'm like
we're like smiling isn't this amazing
like this is where we grew up oh my god
let's go for a while so let's go for a
walk this is so cool so we went
literally on like a little journey
through walk down memory lane together
like hand in hand walking around the
campus reminiscing oh my God that's
where that happened remember when we
used to da da da right and then we got
to I was like where am I gonna do this I
didn't think through like where will I
do it in the campus I just wanted to get
operation get to ues
and then we did like a full circle and
we landed where we used to take yearbook
photos
right and I thought that was a good spot
because we could it you know we'll take
this is where I'll have the moment and
we have so many memories I have
yearbooks of us together in that spot in
these yearbook photos so yeah that we
got to that spot and then I like yeah
dropped on my on one knee and said will
you marry me
and it was so surreal but it was all so
quick and she was like she looked at me
she's like what what she's like wait is
it such a long day she was so confused
it was so jarring that it was like the
whole setup to this point and like was
so confusing then I and then I think I
said it again to make it really real and
then we she said yes you know took a
selfie in that spot and then we went
over to my mom's house and I had had her
dad show up there in advance and then we
walked in and I told he I he didn't know
why
um while he was going to be there and
then we told them and they were so
excited and it was it was really so that
was it wow that's fine that's my whole
podcast
yeah anyway so it all came back around
you know it was the right time and it
all like it all hit at the right time
and what did she say when you told her
that you were gonna propose to her at oh
she was like oh she she was so happy we
waited and we got to this point and it
felt so much stronger would it have been
a no for her then at Ellis Island I
probably would have been yeah I think it
would have just been like wait what are
you doing I'm not ready this is too much
why are you doing this all this we just
moved like what is happening right yeah
I just ate breakfast you just got me
breakfast like this is manic but it was
really yeah it was really it was really
um yes it was really sweet and we have a
friend John DeWall who he proposed to
his wife and I think the first
definitely first time maybe first two
times she said no oh wow but they have
like kids now and they're good how did
was it like an official proposal yeah he
actually got down on one yes and then my
childhood best friend Christina like she
found out that her now husband was gonna
propose and she said and make it stop
and yeah which I cannot relate to it all
because the day I met Dave I started my
campaign to get married to him so like I
just don't understand people wanting to
wait I'm like yeah yeah the um
um yeah anyway but no it's you know it's
yeah it's but that's a real great
practice of restraint I like who years
now yeah yeah but then she couldn't
believe the ring had been in like a bag
I can't believe she never found it yeah
so shitty to just find uh that's like
such a it's true it was in my bag it was
a bag she would never have opened oh
there isn't a bag I would never open
yeah I'm in every single prep well you
know there's going to be something
rotting in the back yeah something to
clean out to throw out yeah
um I think that's a good story about
like the voices in your head like using
them as like a guide but not letting
them be the thing that because it yeah
yeah exactly and if your uncle is
Francis Ford Coppola like you don't have
to do exactly what it is right away you
can wait no but see I never I grew up
like never thinking of marriage never
thinking of babies I never wanted it it
wasn't until I met Dave where I was like
I almost like I didn't want to be with
him if we weren't gonna get married
because I was so afraid of a breakup
with him like I didn't even want to
enjoy him unless I knew it would be
forever which is obviously anxious
attachment
um psychotic or like even anxious such a
trooper Dave we're really proud of him
yeah and it's just so yeah looking back
it's obviously silly because he kind of
it said like just be patient in so many
ways he said that and it's like I
couldn't I I could not absorb that or
trust that you're showing New York that
I was at oh yeah oh yeah you said we're
engaged but we're not gonna get married
or something is that true well so we've
been engaged well we're postponing the
we've been engaged for five years so I
say I say like I'm engaged but it's been
five years so it's not looking good
um got it it was a long engagement but
it really is just that he wants to have
a wedding and I don't and like oh that
is I thought it's something else yeah
that's the thing I think it's something
else I think it's you threaten the idea
of having a dry wedding with no alcohol
yeah by the way it's like Esther that's
so such a nightmare for everyone I did
when I was younger I did think if I were
to have a wedding I would want it to be
dry and no alcohol I think everyone
should be like on the same plane I could
see you just being like no no
everyone just like suffering for your
wedding for some reason
no liquids is so funny have you
completely dropped you guys gotten close
to like is there yeah is it like is
there do you feel like it will there
will be something on the horizon like a
real I do there we keep getting close to
like ideas of just like a really just
like moms and dads and siblings kind of
thing but then I think about my family
and I'm like hmm that's just a big
family no I'm thinking I'm literally
just my mom dad's sister and her kids
but I'm like just dealing with getting
them all in the same way are you do you
think you're kind of like embarrassed
the way you were about the it is like to
just be like to to devote your love to
someone in front of of like my brother
yes and we're not an affectionate family
and like I don't know I just I'm like
nervous about it oh that's what it is
there's a nervous physically closed only
with Dave but not with my family so you
want to like go like I know one of
Todd's friends got married at a UPS
store which is so gangster they just
have people that can just marry me about
a UPS Store I didn't know this you can
literally just go to you'd be like there
are options they have notaries and isn't
that so funny I'm like
the angster
well my parents were married in a
courthouse in Chicago and so I was
thinking like by Mateo Lane's
grandfather I know is his grandfather
still alive I don't know because that
would be pretty good if you could do the
exact same thing but um so we're talking
about maybe doing a courthouse wedding I
don't know if not just exhume exhume his
grandfather dear Mateo Lane you know in
a different way you would yeah why do
you have it at a graveyard that would be
cool I don't think Dee would be
interested I mean it makes sense but
we're not one of those couples where we
have the same interests and can like do
something eccentric like a Halloween
wedding yeah yeah he likes playing poker
what about a Las Vegas wedding I like
that yeah that was like an Elvis I think
I think I'm definitely gonna know this
is so fun so if you wanted twinsies we
can totally double because I can't like
I can't imagine not doing it in Vegas
I was thinking about that but then I
feel like a lot like Kourtney Kardashian
I know but it's like in a little chapel
yeah the reason everyone does it but I
like a maybe a casino themed wedding
like make all my friends dress up as
Blackjack dealers and they give you cash
they feed you like a slot
um it won't be a dry wedding then yeah
you can't imagine well you could do dry
in Vegas it would be even harder for
everybody do you think the guests would
attend they'd all have floss they'd be
so drunk when you try to make things dry
people come in blacked out yeah they
pre-game I think yeah you're right if
you tell people no alcohol people will
show up already blacked out I think that
it's like it's a 2AM curfew
um thing it's like you give you give to
it you cut people off and so we double
up at midnight like we take as many
shots as possible because we know we
only have till 2am I just think I just
think like the reason because I thought
the same thing about Courtney's
Kardashian's wedding for a second
because Todd and I were always like
we'll do like a kind of upscaled like
Elvis thing but it's like the reason
it's tacky is because it's the best
right but they have other there's other
are there other themes maybe they
probably have other themes right you can
do whatever it doesn't just be Elvis
yeah I know you don't you I know you
like Elvis
or something right yes it's an old
Hollywood themed wedding pick your
character just get Trisha Paytas to
dress up like Marilyn Monroe and do it
you could have like an old monster guy
this all sounds like if I'm marrying
myself I can do this we should have you
get kidnapped by a mobs a murder mystery
wedding I will do
wait what kind of wedding did you have
we had a so our wedding was
after I don't I don't love going to
weddings because I find them to be so
slow and like they're just so hard to
sit through like when you go on a Friday
and there's the rehearsal dinner yeah
and then because I go to some ways where
there's so many people has to give a
speech and you're there like trying to
eat take a bite and then someone makes a
speech and then you put your stuff down
and then another guy got and it's like
three hours later your food is like
really old and falling apart but yeah so
usually it's rehearsal dinner Saturdays
like you know like the wedding day thing
ceremony and then the dinner and then
Sunday farewell
but we thought
let's make Friday the wedding
and just have what the rehearsal dinner
group usually is will just be our
wedding group smaller and then let's
just have a party on Saturday it's just
just invite more people just make it a
reception to celebrate oh we got married
and then goodbye brunch on Sunday when
everybody's leaving the family who flew
in so our wedding was real up just in my
mom's backyard we everybody just kind of
like we we're on a tiny little Riser my
brother married us
and uh we didn't do like long-winded you
know like uh vows that were just on and
on and on about declaring love in front
of everyone we just we just my brother
Matthew worked in we he interviewed us
before and we gave little lines about
things we wanted to share and he kind of
worked it into his speech that's cute
but it was like a sweet fun just family
like long to just passing food around
Italian style like people passing pasta
down the thing it wasn't like overdone
and like you know I mean it felt really
fun and grounded a couple speeches and
then it's so funny though on Saturday I
I like to say I wanted to set it up so I
was kind of like during the day it was
really hot so I was kind of setting up
the backyard and making the areas where
we'd all be hanging out
and I think I got really like really
tired and like dehydrated from setting
up the party area
and then I have a wedding you might like
no and then that night and then I know
it's fun to set it up we kind of did it
more DIY style and then
we and then I didn't eat really any food
because I was talking to everybody and
then I'd people kept bringing me drinks
because they were like oh it was fun
they were like oh I know how it is like
it's so hard to get a drink I'll go get
you a drink and they'd like come back
with white wine someone appeared with
like a tequila someone appeared with
like a beer
and like just like nervously drinking
each thing little bits of it not eating
food and then by the end of the night I
like smoked a cigar with my friends at
like two in the morning to say goodbye
and I got I laid in bed with Zoe and I
had the spins and I rolled over and
threw up all over the ground next to the
bed and she was like oh my God are you
throwing up right now oh my God and then
I went I like stumbled I was like so I
felt so sick from not eating and
drinking five types of alcohol and
smoking a disgusting cigar and then I
like stumbled in and like threw a towel
on the ground and then passed out and
then the next day on Sunday I spent the
whole day so nauseous I couldn't even
attend the brunch I loaded in the
champagne bottles to this restaurant
went up into the second floor and just
laid on the couch the whole brunch as
people came upstairs and said goodbye to
me well I was like curled up in a ball
just like bye and like someone brought
me like some special drink to like
juices to help cleanse I threw up again
at the restaurant
it was so that was that's my fun Zoe and
I if you were here she would laugh
because I I threw up on my wedding night
this would not happen I enjoy being a
wife now I'm sorry babe but that's what
love is this would not happen at my
wedding I love it you see you you see
everyone at this yeah there's gonna be
puking everywhere yeah I know because
there's no not gonna have a good excuse
me you just have people passing out from
liquid not having puking up garages
they're gonna be like oh my God is there
water in the distance it'll be the one
time in my life I do cocaine is that
your wedding okay oh my God Esther's
Coke wedding
finally Esther on eyes
dream come true
oh my gosh
um but Dave wants to get married soon
right yeah he told me yeah he said
before you go on make sure you let her
know by the end of this episode you're
gonna be married but if he had it his
way and he just took if he took over the
whole thing would you be married this
year no that's this whole thing because
the strike's going on he no he there's
more time now he hasn't taken it and you
get married at the strike yes there you
go it hasn't taken any steps or any
action so I don't feel like it's that
urgent to him I don't think it's oh I
who will become urgent to me if my wga
health insurance runs out so
there might be something sooner if we
could get some money involved
Healthcare it has always been my dream
to get married for health insurance and
so I can find a second you know we need
to have we need to give you like A Walk
to Remember wedding where we make you
seem sickly like
[Laughter]
oh my God we'll put like shits on you a
movie themed wedding where you're like
but don't you want to be in a hospital
bed and everyone thinks you're sick and
they come like yes say goodbye can we do
that without a wedding just like for fun
yes
um is the theme today engagements and
weddings
oh congrats thanks yeah guys it's
exciting this week it is exciting have
you been talking about the like the
wedding and everything
sort of it is weird that everyone does
like everyone's like their follow-up
question is that and then I guess once
you get married they're like when are
you having kids oh yeah yeah exactly
it's like this is an idiot thing why do
we do well I froze my eggs and
everyone's like when are you gonna have
them I'm like I just froze them can we
discuss this over a banana break yeah
answered by Chiquita
like he might have gotten married in
Vegas but we just want our nieces and
nephews to be there if all the chickens
were there that'll be so fun for them we
I got proposed to in Vegas so and
everyone was there so it was like almost
like should we just we gotta get that
prenup going to it wait are you going to
all right come on
you bring your own pineapple for banana
break yeah this is my new move that's
dude who got that for you Air One
um wait he's gonna be so proud of you
for cutting it yourself no can you cut
can anyone cut a pineapple I feel like
you need training no it's a lot it is
yeah but it's very simple it's very
straightforward you just have to pick
out the eyes you lose uh you just are
going to lose some of the meat because
you gotta
um but there's a little thing you can
use to just pick out the eyes what
can you use just a normal knife what do
you mean pick out the eyes not like a
normal like a cheese size
like a cutting knife yeah we can you
pull up a pineapple real quick look at
his eyes
little things yeah those little things
okay well that just pulls the whole
thing out oh that's awesome a lot of
meat that way that's awesome how does
that even work
I do like canned pineapple mm-hmm God is
that good wait Andy tell us wedding
what's the conversation any details I'm
in shock people are asking me I'm like
this is so crazy people ask right away
but are you excited I am excited I was
saying to them before you got here that
I hate saying fiance so I think I want
to get married sooner than later to get
rid of that it's just like oh such a
weird interim word
um but I think it'll be easy Todd and I
always do things pretty easy
kind of word it's so annoying yeah and
you do there is a demanded like congrat
like thing this is why I switched it no
I say partner and then people are like
what no partner is better and partner
was a struggle for me and partner
confuses people that's fun the thing I
don't understand I mean I get it but I
just have trouble with it
is the whole idea
where like when someone when you stand
and read your vows to somebody
or you read like the idea of reading
some some people memorize the speech or
some people like wing it yeah or they'll
pull it a piece of paper and read this
like long speech yeah but it's I find it
so I mean I really appreciate somebody's
open ability to be vulnerable and
emotional In This Moment
but also I find it's like confusing at
the same time because
you spend all your time together but
usually you're like living together
probably
it's not like you haven't been together
and you're you need to like disclose
this to them it is for the audience yeah
it's forever it's like you're you are
literally you're performing for everyone
here to like reiterate how emotional how
deep your love is or something but it's
not about everyone else it's about you
or are they need to prove it to anybody
are they witnessing this promise you
make right where are you're like saying
I'm not gonna cheat on you I'm gonna
stay with you it's like I think
everyone's like there to hold you
account well there's like another like
weird it's like a thing about God it's
like yeah you're saying well is it
because the vows are religious right
yeah because I think traditionally isn't
the whole well not of a wedding to be
some form of like public declaration and
like having yeah right right in front of
you well there's the section there's the
section where you traditionally fall
back into do you take this do you right
you know that thing is that that's not
your vows that's not the vows yeah the
vows are a little the vows are different
I've always felt relatively
uncomfortable listening to vows
especially when especially if they're
not funny right and do you know that
they're they're trying to be yeah or
they're just too emotional that they're
not even getting the words out oh Todd's
gonna blow it yeah
did you talk about like not everyone
does that
does is that something you see yourself
I'm just curious is that something you
guys we'll probably do something funny
it'll probably be a beat behind a rhyme
it'll be stupid it'll be a lizard there
will definitely be a lot of skinks
there's gonna be a lot of people that
blizzards I just wonder it's weird
because too like skink Fest it's funny
you know Zoe who's listening I love you
babe Zoe give us something I tell you
much I love her you put other things on
she um we love Zoe we're fan yeah I wish
she should just come on yeah why am I
even here right now I should have had
her on we can do an edit or just like
you shouldn't have between both of us
yeah those stories but she when we first
met like I think it took her time to
realize oh you can meet you can meet
someone and have like a good
relationship I think she'd been in not
good relationships where she didn't
almost like trust yeah like a little bit
always like are you like kind of one on
one and one out kind of are you know and
I always I feel like I had to like
almost like it was like she asked me
this question one time we first met we
first got back together I was like do
you think people could really be
together like forever kind of question
and her own I doubt in that at times
this is before she finally let go and
became
I think what she really her true self
because she was had been left over a
feeling of being hurt in the past yeah
but
um but you know there were like times
where she would I like would be very
reactive to if I if I looked at her a
certain way or said a certain thing like
what did you mean by that or like are
you looking like what's wrong like or
are you looking at me like yeah like
very almost like insecure about like
hyper hyper sensitive to what I was
saying when I didn't mean that so
there's a lot of like no no I didn't
mean like overly explaining I can really
relate to clarify like oh no I didn't
mean that yeah but like I could I just
wonder if that there's that person is in
a and it's not by the time we got
married we had reached a new level of
like of feeling at ease with each other
but I wonder if someone's like if you if
you wrote a whole thing out and you said
it if everyone's ever felt like what did
you mean by that when you said that yeah
like we're giving me the love I really
want yeah
exactly relate to her and anyway as like
the way you describe her just being
super mistrustful because she had only
been in her bad relationships like when
I meet a great guy like I met an amazing
guy recently my first question is is he
great or is he a narcissist like I have
such like I'm like am I I almost just
mistrust the situation waiting for the
other shoe to drop will you watch that
woman's YouTube videos too so you're Dr
Romney so you're like hyper aware of
enough yeah so it's like oh my God like
I have no complaints this must be a red
flag yeah or am I being love bombed am I
yeah like he's so amazing oh this is
like I'm now I'm freaking out like I'm
looking for things yeah yeah and I'm now
investing yeah that's tough yeah and I
think I feel like that's a me issue
that's not it but I feel like I don't
know a single woman who doesn't bring
who who hasn't had this past of bad
relationships then then they they have
to always be a little skeptical until
they do find that trust yeah be
protective yeah no I'm not totally and
that's common
um
yeah anyway
so I'll see you guys later
actually Todd's here we're gonna google
that yeah
um no I think vows are weird I went to
my friend's wedding years ago and he got
divorced so it's like when you like see
someone go through and you're going what
are the what are those vowels oh my god
oh no I had like a bicycle wedding they
were like bike they like bikes they
spent like bike jokes this was the most
obnoxious wedding I'd ever seen like it
was a week-long wedding like maybe 800
people a really big to do because they
came from like two big families this is
in Asia
divorced in six months really six months
no way like I I just couldn't what
happened
what was his job and when he when she
confronted him and said hey he was not
willing to stop seeing her or to stop
being a pro you know like oh he had a
family he had another woman but she
didn't know about it obviously okay wait
so I wanted the emerging of families but
she really believed that they were in
love family not just a another but he
had children he had children I believe
so what was this job that he was able to
do that
um he is just an air like an air he's
just the oh just a rich it's so annoying
that women can't have a secret second
family because you'd see our pregnancies
yeah like that I it would just be so
baller if some woman had a secret second
family she's tried that off let's do it
I'll try
I don't wear baggier shirts but
pull off a pregnant honestly guys are so
dumb I could see it like easily
happening they don't even look just be
like I have ascites there's some fluid
shift in my belly and you know I'm going
through some autoimmune stuff and it's
kicking I don't know why it's kicking
[Music]
and then and then the guy's like are you
pregnant like so you think I'm fat yeah
guys are so scared to say like
stand there with like full nine month
pregnant belly and they're like are you
pregnant and you're like
no do you still love do you guys still
love your dog as much no shut up oh no
no different though right because
they're not your baby anymore
we've we Zoe found a miniature schnauzer
that was walking alone like sniffing a
tree by the 101 freeway a long time ago
and we took her and we fostered her and
then kept her Trixie is her name oh and
she was like our dog and then when we
would go on trips
she was a little skittish with kids
but and then she would stay with Zoe's
dad he would look after her and like
they became very tight
it's his best friend and when we had our
twins because durian kovid so he got
pregnant
with some guys baby
somehow I don't know
we are bringing it up
she yeah so we were like let's let's try
and then she got pregnant and happy baby
she got pregnant well we waited a little
bit in January we found out in February
we found it on the table there was two
babies in there wow she had a full
breakdown because she was like I don't
think I can she was really nervous to be
pregnant once with one kid yeah and she
was like she was like I had a full
meltdown were you kind of like psyched
were you like I was yeah because it was
weird because at one point I had made a
comment not being try to be silly or
something but I was like I put my head I
was like laying in bed together and I
was like oh I what if there's two or
something I said something like that
before we knew
and then we and then I thought when the
woman was like oh oh like one baby and
two here's the other baby we were like
what it was it was weird because I had
this like feeling yeah and then I was
like wait is she messing with us and
Zoey's like no wait what and then looked
at the screen and she's like yeah and
then so I was like oh I had a full
meltdown the woman's like hugging her
giving her tissues
yeah it's a nightmare but yeah but and
we we so we confirmed it like a couple
like a month later two months later and
then and then covet a month later the
world shuts down and that was that time
wow but she was she was amazing she
carried both babies to a full full term
38 weeks and um she was I'll show you
photos of the birth I put him up it's on
that's okay that's healing um I've seen
her stomach it was really yeah it was
wild yeah there was two three we have
two boys fraternal twins totally
different look totally different great
totally different personalities really
fun they're almost three so it's getting
wild do you guys know I really connect
to your story and like parents of twins
yeah he's connected to I feel like
do you guys now feel like this cool
relief that like or does she feel or
ever talk about like okay well that's
kind of cool I got two done at once kind
of yeah because well
I think there's a oh you know what
happened like she her mom
got like you know she's very tight with
her mom and her she her mom sort of like
put it out in her head that she was
having two girls
and Zoe spends so much time I think like
with shooting women for fashion and like
she's very close to like a community of
feeling connected to more of like female
energy yeah so when we found out we had
two boys she like she uh she was so
she's like oh my God what do I do two
boys I can't do this I don't know how to
do this
and then it was like no it's going to be
don't worry babe
it's gonna be great yeah I got this but
um but and then now we so we had two and
she's couldn't be more like happy and
yeah connected to them
so but we we always talk about like you
know what if we went tried again and had
like a girl it'd be like fun to have
experienced both sides of raising
children of different we froze embryos
my fiance and I and they're all boys and
I'm like so bummed out and he's you are
yeah I would definitely want because I
just now I love
he's my nieces were first and I like
connected with them so much and my twin
brother's kid I don't know I just like I
always like imagined like I'm like a
like you know I know I really really
would want a girl too yeah but but
everyone who has a boy is so and I love
my it's like they're so cute and they're
so funny and they seem there I feel like
girls and boys are easier and more
difficult in different ways like the
boys are just so crazy like they're just
like running around being insane
screaming all the time and the girls are
like very emotional they were so
emotional since they were so young and
like
like just really feeling everything was
like really intense always but um we I
have friends who have like you know two
daughters my cousin has two daughters
and and it's you always hear stories
when like her kids became teenagers how
hard it gets I mean that's wild and then
like it's always six you you hear you
always hear stories of like both
experiences and it's it each experience
is so unique and subjective but
but um everything has challenges yeah I
feel like that's where my expertise
would pick in just shitty teenagers
shitty girl teenagers because I was a
shitty girl teenager I was just my
parents so I feel like it's like
whatever tricks you have up your sleeve
I've done [__] like but also I do think
yeah I do think I felt like I was gonna
get my comeuppance with that like I did
just assume but who knows if I end up
having kids like naturally or with the
embryos or defrost doing nothing giving
them to Josh Potter to fix his eye
take the stem cells Josh
but um you know whatever whatever
happens happens but I do think I thought
I was gonna get like an evil girl that
was gonna did you know that that's
there's like biological reasons why like
when you're a teenager you start to like
hate your parents it's because when you
once you're like through puberty and at
like you could technically mate you want
to like get away from your parents did I
show this video it was weird yeah yeah
because you're you're not supposed to
like it's to get away from inbreeding
yeah so you like leave your village to
you're supposed to find them like
repulsive so it's like not your fault if
you're like a mean teen yeah you're like
you said it's so much cuter than that
guy it's biology to be a mean team
that's so wild and then or when you but
the sad part is they're like then around
25 when you're no longer in the piece of
reproductive age group you start to like
your parents again like no but if that
were true like we'd all still be hating
our parents because we still need to
meet
um yeah but what I was thinking about
when my when my mom found out the story
of when my mom found out she was
pregnant with twins was she already had
my older brother who was two and a half
at the time and they just wanted to have
two kids and at the ultrasound they said
it was Twins and my dad was like yes
like my sister was strong you know my
mom just started crying and was like
devastated all right yeah it's a lot did
you guys have either of you have twins
in the family
not not in the way that I think would
have would have got us to this point not
no because it just
I mean I think if we if Zoe had
identical twins in her family I think
genetically like the egg splitting I
think that's where genetics maybe plays
a part I mean I don't see how I could if
I had twins in my family how that has an
effect on it really yeah because it
would be it's two eggs or fertilized at
the same time she two eggs are released
the woman has the eggs
oh no because I have a friend who I
think her like
her she's a twin so her mom had her and
then her mom's Brothers
all of three of them had twins oh wow so
and they're all fraternal wow so I do
think there is a genetic all natural
yeah yeah
interesting yeah I know it's weird if
you could just put like yeah but you
know it's so funny when we we didn't we
took a while for us to find the OB that
we used we met so many people and it was
all through covet so it was all on zooms
yeah wow it was like all these zoom and
by the way I wasn't allowed into some of
the doctors right yeah yeah there was
like we were nervous because we were
like oh man what if Cedars doesn't let
me go into the room and like she's
having the kids
so luckily by the time we did we they
were born I was able to go but I sat in
so many sessions and in the car with
with FaceTime on
while Zoe was in the inner appointment
yeah so bizarre like I'll be outside
like parked outside in the car so sad
but um
but yeah we uh every time we called an
OB office we like oh yeah my wife's
pregnant with twins twins oh my God
amazing IVF it was always like yeah no
and I said oh no natural natural
that's amazing
I didn't realize I was like oh really
cool I didn't know it was such a thing
that it was like to do that but do you
guys remember Nadia Suleiman OCTA mom
yes yes you know I was watching this
thing on her like you know what she's
been up to like she's a great mom it
seems like her whole life revolves
around like I don't know if you ever
just seen her talk about her kids but
like she is on her [__] I know she got a
lot of [__] for doing this
but I kind of want to have eight babies
at once that would be so cool
you would have like you would they would
have to split you from your neck of your
[__] to get those babies out I mean
it's hard you know it's really hard
they'd have to gouge out the eyes it's
amazing to have you know be able to
raise eight at the eight babies at the
same time with diaper changes feeding is
really and she had no
father right it was all like sperm donor
yeah breeding Kink for sure I mean I
have a breeding kick but it does not
look like this it doesn't involve like
if you try to get many is this what was
this like
why why did it suddenly did she put
eight eggs I think she put more and I
think eight I like the one little ginger
ones yeah so she chose to have many at
the same time oh look at the little
redhead with blue eyes she came out the
same time as a tan mom oh a lot of weird
you were more of a tan mom I was a spray
tan mom the kid with the red hair was
just he was just photo bombing yeah
he's like he was just walking by he's a
neighbor you see that um vegan
influencer who just passed away no from
starvation but I was gonna say she was
all excited no because I thought you
were gonna say that there was like this
this um sperm bank or something came out
with this information that like people
won't accept sperm donations from
redheads that's so crazy I think that
that I I think they're re-accepting now
because I think for a while there they
were like let's hold off on the redheads
but you're not really I get along with
redheads because I feel like they've
been through a lot like you know what I
mean like I'm like you guys have been
through some [__] but I think if it's
still a business and no one is you know
that was crazy no one is asking for
redheads you have to have gone to
college too I think to are you talking
about egg zester or sperm sperm yeah
that's right because I don't think women
were going in there at that time asking
like buying
um you know specifically like jeans for
right
well Robert thank you so much that's it
did someone die kicking me off wait what
did I do
oh yeah yeah sorry the veganism you
don't want to make this a double episode
shall we have a double I didn't feel
done Annie does a surprise I got the
signal you guys are blaming me I
responded to the signal light on in the
back no they they move something over to
know that we're at our time
um should we throw it to our sponsors
Chiquita banana
that's a really good idea no
um but thank you so much for being here
this was awesome thank you I'm so happy
I'm here thank you thank you for being
you kind of gave us your vows in a weird
way you did the thing we all got married
today oh yeah thank you no I'm happy I'm
here and I was nice to be here and yeah
and ask her good to see you yeah you
know yeah this is awesome so what do we
do now well yeah we'll see you guys next
week with a brand new episode and check
out Robert on Instagram and Google him
and see how fabulous he is it's at
Robert Schwartzman check it out that's
s-c-h-w-a-r-e-z-m-a-n
all right take care
[Music]